with sways of the UK underwater many
communities are slowly being cut off
through Worcestershire Gloucestershire
and South Wales we found road after road
inundated with floodwater motorists have
been warned not to put themselves in any
danger
many roads will remain closed for days
to come at six o'clock people get
through and we didn't have any road
closure signs put up so people continue
to go through and I think from about
seven eight o'clock that's when they got
into trouble in their cars stuck and
with River levels rising some residents
have already become trapped
Tony Kells home on the river 7 is now
surrounded by raging flood water but he
is unconcerned but you're completely cut
off that's a good thing people living
this close to nature having to get used
to more unpredictable weather and that
means coping with almost regular floods
but more areas are becoming at risk as
Britain storms carry more water than
ever before the levels of flooding in
parts of the country are now
unprecedented we're very close to the
river why here this road has been
completely submerged and you could see
why entire communities are cut off I'm
walking around places like this it's a
very strange sight it's eerie most of
the houses have been evacuated and look
through the window over here people's
furniture their possessions all their
stuff just floating around in the dirty
floodwater and what's more forecasters
say with more rain and gale force winds
on their way this is likely to get worse
before it gets better
in Monmouth in South Wales police have
closed this bridge it's feared the sheer
volume of water could cause it to
collapse
many people have been stuck outside in
the cold for hours trying to get home
you know since I've are 7-1 I took a few
photographs when everybody else is
walking across the bridge rules are
rules I suppose it's just frustrating
from above huge expanses of land an hour
swamped by flood water this is iron
bridge in Shropshire the Environment
Agency says four hundred and seventy
tons of water are passing through here
every second the flood barriers are
holding that many buildings are being
evacuated just in case and climate
scientists say we can expect more of
this in the years to come
climate change is causing global warming
and global temperatures to increase for
every degree of warming we see a 7%
increase in the air to store water vapor
that means that when we have flooding
events as we've seen in the UK those are
becoming more intense because of climate
change there are still hundreds of flood
warnings in place and that is unlikely
to change anytime soon and with so much
rain over the last few weeks it could be
some time before the country dries out
Alex Rossi Sky News in South Wales